at Stage 5 you'll discover how identity
is constructed self-offering realize
that your values are not terminal but
they are instrumental to achieving a
world that you like in Aesthetics that
you prefer yeah and the more you
understand this the more you get agency
over how your identity is constructed
and you realize that identity and
interpersonal interaction is a costume
and you should be able to have agency
over that question right it's useful to
Via costume it tells something to others
and it allows to interface in roles but
being locked into this is a big
limitation the word costume kind of
implies that it's fraudulent in some way
his costume a good word for you like to
present ourselves to the world in some
sense I learned a lot about costumes at
Burning Man before that I did not really
appreciate costumes and saw them more as
uniforms like wearing a suit if you are
working in a bank or if you are trying
to get startup funding for uh from a VC
in Switzerland right then you dress up
in a particular way and this is mostly
to show the other side that you are
willing to play by the rules and you
understand what the rules are but um
there is something deeper when you write
Burning Man your costume becomes
self-expression and there is no boundary
to the self-expression you're basically
free to wear what you want to express
other people what you feel like this day
and uh what kind of interactions you
want to have is the customer kind of
projection
of uh of Who You Are
that's very hard to say because the
costume also depends on what other
people see in the costume and this
depends on the context that the other
people understand and you have to create
something if you want to that is legible
to the other side and that means
something to yourself
do we become prisoners of the costume
because everybody expects us some people
do but um I think that once you realize
that you we are costume at Burning Man a
variety of costumes realize that you
cannot not wear a costume yeah right
basically everything that you wear and
present to others is something that is
to some degree in addition to what you
are deep inside so this stage in
parentheses you put full adult
Karma wisdom why is this full adult
why would you say this is full
and why is it wisdom it does allow you
to understand
um why other people have different
identities from yours and it allows you
to understand that the difference
between people who vote for different
parties and might have very different
opinions and different value systems is
often the accident of where they are
born and what happened after them after
that to them and what traits they got
before they were born and at some point
you realize the perspective where you
understand that everybody could be you
in a different timeline if you just flip
those bits
how many costumes do you have
I don't count but in more than one yeah
of course
how easy is to do costume changes
throughout the day
it's just a matter of energy and
interest when you are wearing your
pajamas and you switch out of your
pajamas into say a work short and pants
you're making costume change right and
if you are putting on the Gown you're
making a costume change you could do the
same with personality
you could if if that's what you're into
there are people which have multiple
personalities for interaction in
multiple roles right so if somebody
works in a store and you put up a
storekeeper personality when you're
working when you're presenting yourself
at work you develop a step personality
for this and the social persona for many
people is in some sense a puppet that
they are playing like a marionette and
if they play this all the time they
might forget that there is something
behind this just something what it feels
like to be in your skin and I guess it's
very helpful if you're able to get back
into this and for me it's the other way
around is relatively hard for me it's
pretty hard to learn how to play
consistent social roles for me it's much
easier just to be real
or not real but to have
a one costume
no it's not quite the same so basically
when you are wearing a costume at
Burning Man and say you are an
extraterrestrial Prince
um there's something where you are
expressing in some sense something is
closer to yourself than the way in which
you hide yourself behind a standard
closing when you go out in the city in
the default world
and so this costume that you're wearing
at Burning Man allows you to express
more of yourself and uh you have a
shorter distance of advertising to
people
what kind of person you are what kind of
interaction you would want to have with
them and so you get much earlier into
media Express and I believe it's
regrettable that we do not use the
opportunities that we have this
custom-made closing now to wear costumes
that are much more stylish that are much
more custom-made that are not
necessarily part of a fashion in which
you express which milieu you're part of
and how up to date you are but you also
Express
how you are as an individual and what
you want to do today and how you feel
today and what you intend to do about it
well isn't it easier now with in the
digital world
to uh
to explore different costumes I mean
that's the kind of idea with virtual
reality that's the idea even with
Twitter in two-dimensional screens you
can you can swap all costumes you can be
as weird as you want it's easier for
burning man you have to like order
things you have to make things you have
to it's more effort to it's better if
you make them yourselves
sure but it's just easier to do
digitally right it's not about easy it's
about how to get it right and for me the
first Burning Man experience I got
adopted by a bunch of people in Boston
who direct me to Burning Man and we
spent a few weekends doing costumes
together and that was an important part
of the experience where the camp bonded
that people got to know each other and
we basically grew into the experience
that we would have later so the
Extraterrestrial Prince is based on a
true story yeah
[Music]
I can only imagine what that looks like
yosha